this is a wonderful opportunity to be
here and I'd like to thank everybody who
made it possible once again i think my
talk actually takes off from where the
questions ended in the morning session i
working with the machina collection
actually brought me to working with that
very different other kind of archive
that we were talking about the film
archive so four years ago I started
working intensively in the film archive
and so my dessert my presentation here
is basically about working up to that
point from the Maquis no collection to
what I'm doing now destination Japan is
the working title of my current research
and investigation of Japan as a foreign
destination in visual material culture
of the first half of the 20th century I
chose to talk about my experience with
the Maquis no collection and to think
about its connection to destination
Japan for three reasons first mr Mackey
knows approach toward building and using
his collection modeled the process of
forming a working collection of primary
sources including common use otherwise
expendable objects second my current
work raises questions and possible lines
investigation that suggest how the
machina collection might be used to
better understand silent film history
mr. rocky know is interested in almost
everything but film prints and many of
the film's relevant to materials in the
collection are lost however mr Mackey
know had a special interest in
nonfiction films and there are good
reasons why these films and silent
amateur films Shannon formats smaller
than 35 millimeter might turn up on an
archive shelf or surface some other way
third when I discussed that destination
Japan with mr Mackey know a few years
ago when the collection was still in his
possession I benefited from one of his
famous dig then discuss again dig
sessions so I know that what I'm working
on will bring me back to the collection
all the different presentations today
reflect the Marquis no collection
significance as a multidisciplinary
resource I'll focus on its potential for
silent film research and fill
servation and start with background that
provides useful context it film studies
began as a neglected child of the
academic curriculum film itself spent
its early life as an orphan abandoned by
the production companies that made then
moving pictures were not systematically
collected and maintained on an
institutional basis until after silent
cinema ended University film courses in
a body of film scholarship followed the
scholarship depended on the work of film
archives but academics and archivists
were separated by a curiously artificial
professional divide this capsule outline
describes the situation in the United
States in Europe but it was different in
Japan the National Film Center in Tokyo
wasn't established until the 1950s and
legitimization of academic film studies
in Japan today is still a work in
progress I should add that even in the
United States the discipline is still
often commonly volleyed back and forth
between the predominantly European and
American centric departments of English
in art history this hasn't served the
interests of Asian Film Studies very
well in Europe in the United States the
1978 international federation of film
archives or Fiat brightened conference
was instrumental in bringing archivists
and film scholars together watching
early films side by side they launched a
provocative revision of early film
history especially after the
moving-picture centenary in the 1990s
the study preservation and archiving of
silent cinemas remains grew
exponentially bringing opportunities for
archival research in an increase in the
number of silent film theatrical
screenings new discoveries and
restoration projects followed and it's
now common for such projects to develop
as collaborations between two or more
archives again this summary only
describes the trajectory a silent film
research in Europe always ahead of the
curve with government funding for
cultural heritage in the United States
with the National Film Preservation
Foundation has provided funding
opportunities for preservation projects
since I
96 a copper level of preservation
archiving and increased scholarship
became possible in Asia only during the
last decade the National Film Archive in
Tokyo joined the International
Federation of Film Archives in 1995 and
now subscribes in principle to general
fiat policy the 2002 Fiat annual
conference was held at the Korean Film
Archive and it was the organization's
first annual meeting in Asia a turning
point for asian film preservation and
film studies currently the head of the
Tokyo National Film Center is Fiasco
president a silent film studies
explosion made feasible by increased
preservation and access is at this very
moment becoming a reality for those of
us studying Japan's early cinema annual
programming for the ported on a silent
film festival the largest exclusively
silent film festival since it began in
nineteen eighty-two confirms an
increased interest in early Asian cinema
in the 1990s pordenone featured the
first curator programs of films from
India and China in the 1990s sorry
japanese film has been featured five
different years to date beginning in
2001 this year's festival held last
month included two substantial programs
of silent animated shorts made in Japan
after the last screening National Film
Center representatives announced their
commitment to ensuring Japanese films
are included in the festival yearly from
now on the survival rate for Japanese
feature film is depressing these are the
figures that they gave at last year's
Pordenone conference but there are still
other films that they can show for
screening these films they can always
recommend in the future these films are
now primary primary focus of early film
research because they educate us beyond
the Canon and I received knowledge of
film history I'll put the machina
collections role in advancing Japanese
silent cinema studies and archival
practice into sharper perspective by
saying a little about my own Makino
experience my first encounter with the
name Makino Mamoru was at the Shinjuku
branch of kinokuniya in the film
section this was probably sometime
around nineteen eighty six or seven
because what I saw was an announcement
for the newly published a catsuit dijo
reprint series an early example of mr
Mackey knows many efforts to provide
increased access to foundational primary
material I took something for future
reference I think it was an
advertisement I fervently hope it was
not another books paper OB if it was an
OB I might be forgiven because in those
days even secondary sources on pre 1950s
Japanese cinema or scarce I remember how
astonished I was to see this material
reprints of censorship records from
nineteen twenty five to nineteen
forty-three actually available for
purchase I'd arrived in Japan in the
mid-1980s to do field work for doctoral
dissertation on the screenwriter Yatta
Yatta I knew relatively little about
silent cinema in Japan I had faithfully
attended all the screenings at the 1981
music ooty retrospective at the japan
society in the Museum of Modern Art in
New York several years earlier as a
college student I'd studied with Yoda
and other Kyoto film cohorts at Osaka
University of Arts and they provided me
another window on how much I was missing
nulla birches 1979 study of Japanese
cinema to the distant observer also
stoked interest in early cinema for
everyone who read it at the time in 1987
I began teaching at ibaraki University
and after that I commuted to Yoda's home
and kill to every few months as Yoda and
I talked to it off and stop mid-sentence
run upstairs and grab a copy of an old
screenplay or journal for one of the
amateur film clubs he belonged to it is
you at the time of our meetings he was
writing about the man he considered his
first mentor the film director mudada me
know dude and that's how I became
interested in the pure film movement I
didn't realize it then but yo does
discuss dig discuss again approach to
our working together was my pre Makino
period of training I finally met mr.
machina on a tour of the national film
centres film falls in sagamihara
sometime after my kinokuniya encounter I
recognized his name and was excited to
meet him we talked he asked me about my
studies I said I was working on a
doctoral dissertation about
screenwriting in Japan
from the industry's origins to sometimes
significantly later I remember this well
because he widened his eyes immediately
and suggested I might want to reconsider
that later date he seemed more
interested when I mentioned focusing on
lost films titles commonly encountered
in secondary sources but now the stuff
of legend because they're not known to
survive he asked if I had thought about
what would happen if any of these films
actually showed up after I'd finished
writing this time I stared with wide
open eyes because I hadn't thought of
that at all as a liability this
conversation marked a turning point
determining the direction of my thesis I
knew I couldn't tiptoe around a film
only because it was no longer available
for formal analysis and the textual
sources i was using were valuable links
to those lost images but my objective
was not limited to a recuperation of
visual narratives alone on the train
back to Eva rocky that night I decided
mr. machina had a real knack for putting
these in other people's bonnets yogesh
captain became ill with pancreatic
cancer in 1990 and died one year later
mr Mackey know immediately took me under
his wing as he did for so many others he
invited me to his home generously
sharing his collection his enthusiasm
and his knowledge each time I visited he
was always prepared with several stacks
of material that he knew I would find
useful and he never showed me anything
without priceless commentary and endless
layers of background information I was
familiar with the usual research
collections but had found no other
accessible source for the material in
which I was interested at the time this
was anything related to writing for the
screen which included draft scenarios
screenplays shooting scripts vinci
scripts continuities and countless
variants of motion picture novelizations
which mr Mackey no had even for other
countries besides Japan I received mr.
Makino's new book last week the book
that's on the table outside just in time
to remind me of details of a time I
recall only as a frantic blur mr.
machina always kept a much better record
of my Makino activity characteristically
thorough he's written that for one year
I made weekly trips from ibaraki
prefecture to kokubunji in order to
scavenge his archive making quote a
maximum
800 in the minimum of four hundred
copies at a time at a local convenience
store this material in machi no steady
flow of reprint publications were vital
sources as i reworked my dissertation
into a book writing in life to me the
contrast between writing and light and
my dissertation partially based on
research I had completed before using
amake no collection is striking for
example nearly all of the illustrations
in the book are from the Maquis no
reprint series in the case of
periodicals organizing these projects
and tattled locating other sources often
other private collections to provide the
issues that were needed to complete each
volume writing and light refers to films
and even entire genres that can no
longer be seen I would have had very
little if anything to represent such
work without the frame captures and
advertisements in those reprints in the
process of preparing these illustrations
I gained a perspective on my subject
that I had not anticipated and it
rekindled my interest in working with
the visual image this was in the days
before digital scanning and as I looked
through the camera lens to put images in
focus I found myself riveted to the
compositional and total beauty that was
apparent even in the reproductions of
these skillfully shot frames there's a
sentence in the introduction to writing
in life that I would not write today in
an attempt to give the reader a sense of
the constraints of silent film research
i wrote a large part of the challenge in
understanding the nature of the silent
japanese film industry lies in learning
how to work within the boundaries of
what is feasible reading this today I
realized the extent to which mr. Makino
and his collection have been so
important to my education I've learned
to focus instead on overcoming these
constraints in order to redraw those
boundaries I've learned much more from
working with mr Mackey notice collection
but I'll conclude with a few examples of
the material I'm now using to find the
destination Japan that only these
objects can provide i also have a film
excerpt shot in japan by an American
tourist Charles Wyeth sometime between
in 1932 that is part of the George
Eastman collection why its world tour of
Jarrett of Japan in Cherry Blossom time
is a record of a tour of Imperial Japan
a period well represented in the Maquis
no collection finding it was part of a
fortuitous twist in the course of my
work I began this project as a
deliberate attempt at non film focused
research because I was sick of working
with non-existent films the project
unexpectedly circled back to film only
this time they're real identifying
contextualizing and appreciating these
surviving films is one way in which the
collection will be useful our
perspective on film history is biased by
what we could see the personal accounts
like this travel film show us something
easily overshadowed by other visual
records they embody the subjective
experience of the everyday my first
sensation of what Japan must have looked
like to foreign tourists in the 1920s
and 30s came while watching a 1920s
Japanese feature film in pordenone in
2001 I thought I recognized the shot
location from a recently purchased
picture postcard of coalbed starting to
collect postcards was one result of
having been immersed for so long in a
period of filmmaking with no surviving
images at first I just enjoyed their
beauty which reminded me of early
methods of hand coloring silent film and
then i discovered the sensation of riri
encinia as objects of human
communication instead of all too
familiar disparagement january sees
tourism as flexible and inclusive as
well as constructed in linking the flow
20th century material culture and
cultural identity I've borrowed his
perspective because of the close
historical affinity of tourism and
education and their similarity as
processes of subjective identity
formation I also widened my parameters
to interpret tourism as temporarily
limited travel both actual physical
experiential and virtual educational
informational the wide variety of
promotional educational and
entertainment material that
collected or located in other
collections represents a snapshot rather
than any sort of complete canon that's
why I'm building an international of an
interactive online component that will
allow me to solicit contributions and
commentary from other participants in NH
Summer Institute in 2002 was influential
in giving shape to the project and I've
been teaching a course to complement
this research on an average of every two
years since then and I'm just showing a
few of the images this is one of my
favorite of course because of the
personal inscription on the postcard but
just to give you an idea of the variety
of the material material i give you of
japan as a member of the movement of
internationalisation japan and
expositions japan actually I didn't know
til I found this postcard where you see
postmark Rochester 1919 forget the date
actually a 1911 but it's um apparently
there was some exhibit of Japan at the
exact area of each Park in Rochester so
I'm learning things that have happened
locally from collecting this material
Japan conjured up as an amusement park
of the very well known Japan gardens in
Wonderland Revere Beach Massachusetts
images and objects not with Japanese
origin trade collecting cards sheet
music I should say that the intersection
between promoting business and tourism
is
very fascinating a common subjective
categories of foreign origin tourist
brochures the shipping lines that were
so active in the the interwar period
published an enormous amount of material
stereo views and just some of the many
magazines that are available to see my
attention was roughly brought back to
working with moving images when i bought
a film can on ebay for twenty dollars
that turned out not to be empty real two
of me pongo josei a film by the boris
board of tourist industry taught me that
photochemical film is actually not
entirely mechanically reproducible it is
organic a trans mutable tangible object
that carries evidence of its own past
production and use the film was in an
advanced stage of decomposition and my
colleagues at George Eastman House wrote
up an estimate of what it would cost to
reserve the single real the National
Film Center couldn't confirm whether or
not they had a unique copy and I
eventually failed to save it but holding
it in my hands was enough to make me
realize I needed to learn more about the
physical nature of film film as an
object a new direction for my research
and in a fortuitous turn of events I
just realized that Professor Yokogawa
has actually seen a copy of this film at
the british war museum and we were very
excited to share this piece of
information so I'm just going to now
yeah to now scroll through a few images
from some of the other films that I
found this is a tourist promotional film
from 1916 this is on 35 millimeter its
nitrate I took the photo
from the nitrate print but it has been
transferred to safety fill and restore
this is an amateur film that was shot in
japan i believe in the late 20s um
actually the invite event in the early
30s because the film stock there were
two different kinds of film stock in the
film and what's interesting about it was
the person who shot the film was a
member of the amateur cinema Lee and
their interest in film culture in Japan
is fascinating first of all besides
these kinds of everyday scenes they also
he I believe is that she ran into a film
in production in the countryside while
she was traveling around so there's some
shots that she took of the various
people who were acting in the film when
she died a key I don't know where but
she has a little title card that
explains how they ran into this and how
fortunate she felt and then she has
pictures footage of the box office in a
Saxa which for me was extremely exciting
I'd seen photographs of it but I'd never
really seen it in action and other
photographs of saxa as well so um my
powerpoint presentation stops here and
I'm going to conclude with this eight
minute film by Charles why it was one of
three wheels that were too bad state of
decomposition they were preserved so
they are available for access it was a
tourist named Charles Wyatt
it was deposited the George Eastman
House in 1989 and the records weren't
very clear but presumably by by a
relative it's already been preserved
it's one of three wheels um in terms of
where if I we could recognize a few of
the locations but what's most curious to
me is that I've see a few of these now
and everybody seems to pick on all the
people who take these films pick on some
different motifs always with more time
spent filming people than the places
themselves which I find very interesting
i don't know if you noticed but mr.
Wyatt had a real interest in people who
are carrying things he was really
fascinated the amateur film that I
showed you earlier it was fief there was
just scene after scene every once in a
while there would be like a whole
montage of different kinds of footwear
so sometimes they follow a narrative
pattern they very often will start with
a map of Japan that will show the route
there's often some shots that are taken
on the boat and then they go through the
various towns you can sort of trace the
itineraries from the kinds of artists
itineraries that were being advertised
at the time in the Japanese publication
tourists which was published bilingually
and they would tell you whether it was a
nine-day tour 10-day tour to too weak to
her um let's see what else I think you
can recognize the Imperial Hotel which
was interesting and of course there's
the colonization dimension which for me
I thought that I had studied Asia pretty
well and when I saw these images I
really felt that I was having a
sensation about a period of Japan's
history that I had not gotten from books
and I think that's one of the way that
these amateur films can be so incredibly
informative and exciting you didn't
notice I think a couple of shots of
Mount Fuji
the clouds he did finally get it without
the clouds i just thought i would put
that in there so thank you very much